all right joining us now is 2024
Republican presidential candidate former
vice president Mike Pence is with us Mr
Vice President I want to ask you right
off the top here you know a lot of this
if we go back to the Iraq War which you
are very very familiar and you you think
of of those moments and you think of
fuan you think of mosul and you think of
some of the toughest moments uh when you
thought when you think of the the reboot
of of the conflict because mistakes were
made early right uh
military technology has become way more
sophisticated it has advanced to levels
where Wars can be fought by people in
American cities pushing buttons and with
pinpoint accuracy hitting targets
hitting you know the the head of a pin
for crying out loud which is how
sophisticated it is my question to you
when you marry this new technology
military technology and Ingenuity uh to
these conflicts how does it change the
look of War does it take away some of
the component of risk going door too
stepping over IEDs in the
process well well first let me let me
just say I think it's extremely
important that we speak with one voice
as a nation that America stands with
Israel that we will stand with Israel
tonight we will stand with Israel when
this ground assault begins and we will
stand with Israel every day through the
hard fighting and loss that will occur
uh until they achieve an outright
Victory they have no choice in this
moment but to crush Hamas I mean you and
I both know we we live through these
years 2005 the Bush Administration
decided to turn Gaza over to Hamas uh
it's been a catastrophic failure it's
been a policy of containment can't be
that anymore that horrific assault
claiming 1300 lives of men women and
infant children must be met uh with a
with a crushing response that ends Hamas
as a threat from Gaza uh once and for
all now I I'm very heartened to hear
some of your guests say that Israel is
today focused on hostage rescue I I had
hoped that President Biden would direct
uh joint Special Operations Command our
Delta Force our Navy Seals to work in
close proximity with Israeli Defense
Forces uh because we've got Americans
that are held hostage and I I respect at
least the reporting that just happened
on your broadcast that there's a focus
on getting our hostages home but look I
I think we ought to be making it clear
that with Americans In Harm's Way with
our cherished Ally Israel suffering this
brutal assault and now hostages being
held uh that we ought to make it clear
to Hamas that they either turn them over
or we're coming in and we're coming in
hard I mean I have no doubt the IDF
hostage rescue Personnel special forces
are the are the top of their game but
we're the best in the world and there
are Americans involved one other thing I
would say to you Sean is you know we
heard one of your guests a moment ago
talk about uh the the uh the the border
to Egypt is closed that is totally
unacceptable If I Was President of the
United States I'd be on the phone with
President LCC and I would be saying open
your border let's start with women and
children and and send us the bill we'll
set up the refugee camps but the the
very idea that Egypt uh for whom we
Supply Military Support and components
of but for whom we have partnered in uh
in taking down terrorist elements in in
Sinai during our Administration would be
shutting their door uh in this dire hour
is utterly unacceptable and lastly If I
Was President you know the the USS
Eisenhower battle group I think just
pushed off yesterday I I would end any
debate about that at the Pentagon of the
White House I would Direct direct them
to the Eastern Mediterranean have them
pull alongside the USS Gerald Ford
aircraft carrier battle group so we send
a clear message to Iran a clear message
to Hezbollah in Lebanon a clear message
to osma Assad's murderous regime in
Syria that all of them are to stand down
uh and uh and if a wider War ensues here
the United States will stand shoulder
toosh shoulder to defend the Jewish
state of Israel Mr Vice President let me
ask you this because
Isis grew under the Obama Biden
Administration Isis was destroyed under
the Trump Pence
Administration uh it didn't get a lot of
fanfare when you really look back on it
but it was a
sophisticated military strategic effort
that literally went backwards and it and
as they grew they began to shrink and
you wipe you wiped out the caliphate and
it got very little notice you got very
little credit for it but you did it with
overwhelming military force and the
Precision technology that I I have been
bringing up all night I ask you based on
the technology that you have far more
far more knowledge of than I do and that
our audience would have with that
technology how how possible is it to use
strategies that defeated Isis in this
case I know it's more complicated
because of the hostages that we've been
talking about all night um but those
strategies be applied
here well look thanks for giving credit
to the Armed Forces of the United States
look the it was Barack Obama who called
Isis the JV remember that I do and then
then they took over a land mass the size
of uh
Ohio at the end of the day uh our
Administration Unleashed our military we
essentially took the safeties off and we
said take the fight to them and and I
think everything begins when you're
dealing with terrorists which Hamas I I
heard some of those protesters talking
about that that uh that about free
Palestine or how they they were against
killing civilians look Hamas did not
invade Israel to free Palestine they
invaded Israel to kill Jews and it's
their objective it's their goal to kill
Jewish civilians to essentially Drive
Israel to its knees and drive Israel out
of existence and and uh and so I I think
the first the first order of business is
to make make it clear that uh that that
you're going to take the safeties off
that you're going to lean in with regard
to the Precision technology look Isis in
many cases was out in the open they were
spread out over a large region this is
going to be house-to-house stuff it's
much more analogous to what you just
referred to Sean as that surge that took
place in places like radi in the Iraqi
War this this is going to be hard
fighting and it's it literally is going
to be building by building house by
house uh and and it's one of the reasons
why I think it's absolutely imperative
that that uh that Palestinians living in
Gaza take take to heart those leaflets
take to heart the warnings get out of
those areas because Israel is going to
have to move in they're going to have to
move in with heavy armor but they're
going to have to move in with
overwhelming Force house to uh just like
the surge did in Iraq uh and and it will
it they're going to have to do
everything in their power to hunt down
and destroy the 30 40,000 uh Hamas uh
terrorists hold up in Gaza today are you
suggesting and do you think the American
people will be accepting of Boots On The
Ground American boots on the ground in
the case of Hostage
rescue well look it's it's what our
Delta Force and Navy Seals do better
than anybody in the world and we're
talking about Americans here right Sean
I mean I I know I know there's some
other people in the public debate on our
side of the aisle that are questioning
American commitment American involvement
they like to use words like boots on the
ground but I'm talking about Americans
held hostage in Gaza and I I'm just
telling you I've been in the Situation
Room a lot I we this is a moment where
you tell joint Special Operations
Command to begin immediately to to
prepare to mobilize whether it's Delta
Force or whether it's a Navy Seals work
with the Israeli defense for of Special
Operations uh and and and as I said
before make it clear to Hamas that you
either turn them over or we're coming
we're going to come and get them uh and
and we're going to bring them out we're
better at that than anybody in the world
I think we need to be prepared to do it
uh but uh at at the end of the day look
this is this is a moment where there's
there's there are tragic days ahead uh
and I I just want to prepare the
American people the fact that when when
we say America stands with Israel we
have to be prepared to stand today
tomorrow and every day until they
achieve outright Victory and Destroy
Hamas once and for all and I will Mr
Vice President thank you for being with
us tonight we appreciate it uh as you
are watching this is in real time Gaza
being bombarded a massive air uh
offensive by Israel into Gaza hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else